Hello guys, my name is Faiz and I want to thank you guys for trusting me and I want to thank you guys for purchasing this course. Now this is an introduction video and I want to tell you guys what I will be teaching you in this course. So, first of all, we are going to learn about market structure.
structure what is a change of character what is imbalance or farewell gap
whatever you want to call it what is an auto block what is a reactionary auto
block what is supply what is demand and after that we are gonna learn our main
trading strategies so I have around eight trading strategies and I will teach
each and every strategy that I use.
Now, first of all, we are going to learn
Asian session liquidity strategy.
After that, it's gonna be New York session liquidity strategy.
Then auto-flow trading strategy.
And on number four, we have the eight,
third, the AM trading strategy.
After that, we're gonna learn about
under over pattern trading strategy.
and then ABC Trading Strategy.
And then we have the ABC D Trading Strategy.
And at last we have the reactionary blog trading strategy.
Now you are not going to find any of these strategies
on YouTube or on any other courses.
This is my own system that I have created
through back testing.
I will not teach you the basic SMC strategies.
And I am sure they do not work as good as these strategies.
So, once again, I want to thank you guys
for purchasing this course.
And I can guarantee in the next three to four months,
you are going to make a lot of money and trust me,
if you put your effort and hard work in this course,
you're gonna become a really, really good trader.
So thank you once again and I will see you in the next video.